[Music]
we are going around digging holes right
like just trying to poke around for
something where the center mama breaks
it's not black holes it's not you know
wadded up socks in interstellar space
it's not rocks it's not dust particles
you just cannot solve within the
framework of the theories that we
currently use you need an entirely
different type of theory the laws of
physics
learn
how to be the best laws as the universe
allows
[Music]
an issue with physics which i think many
people even outside of the field will be
probably aware of which is that here's
our most successful most powerful theory
almost in all of science quantum
mechanics the theory of the the
sub-atomic world
so powerful so successful without it we
wouldn't understand so much of the
modern world we wouldn't be having this
discussion that's certainly our computer
because we wouldn't have understand
understood and developed modern
electronics so quantum mechanics works
and it's brilliant and it describes um
our universe on the tiniest scale and
yet
somehow we've managed to get away with
not having
an a single agreed upon narrative
interpretation story of what the
mathematics
means everybody has an attitude with a
special kind of mechanics it's a little
bit like what's your religion
yeah
that's right it's interesting isn't it
and we try as particularly as physicists
to say no you know we are objective we
don't you know follow
physics isn't an ideology as as i'm sure
you did as probably you know
all physicists of our generation we were
trained we learned quantum mechanics uh
following the standard the copenhagen
view the textbook view while i haven't
fixed on one particular interpretation
to say that yes it's definitely many
worlds there are many universes this is
you know
i subscribe to this you know
dogmatically
the one of you i do feel strongly about
is that
it cannot simply be a matter of
philosophical taste or choice
how we think nature is
you know we have an embarrassment of
these different interpretations the way
we explain what the math tells us about
the world whether it's copenhagen
whether it's relational whether it's
quantum basianism whether it's many
worlds whether it's
de broglie bone there's all these
wonderfully named exotica
all strange in their own way
all easy to argue against from another
perspective because every one of them
has some strangeness in it
um my view is that one of them has to be
right
and the others are wrong
because i think nature behaves in a
certain way
independently of our debates and
arguments and discussions either there
are parallel universes or there aren't
you know either there are hidden
variables or there aren't either the
universe is deterministic or
indeterministic
um
i tend to be if i if i'm asked to sort
of pick one that i prefer
i tend to to prefer sort of the the more
realist interpretations that there's an
objective reality which i guess probably
goes against relation quantum mechanics
because that would say that you know an
atom doing what it's doing
it's doing something you know regardless
of you and i having different views on
it
it's doing something and quantum
mechanics should tell us what it is do
what it's doing it's been behaving
quantum mechanically before humans
arrived for you know life emerged four
billion years ago on earth
and so it can't simply be
a world that somehow
um conjured into into or crystallized
into reality by our observations
so
it may be that sits underneath you know
maybe relational quantum mechanics is
all quantum mechanics can tell us it can
you know how how we perceive the world
but maybe underneath that there is some
objective reality that we may or may not
ever one day reach but i sort of feel
that
it has to exist there independently of
our observations
the mystery is yeah but what about the
classical world aren't we made of atoms
and aren't we quantum as well they're
a remarkable difference of opinions in
the community each one of them has a
very high philosophical cost they ask us
to realize that something we thought
before was wrong
that there's more in the world than what
we just see
maybe there are hidden variables that we
can never measure maybe there are other
words and maybe there is a
so the question now is which which
perspective is more useful
and uh the debate is open and i think it
has been changing
the relational quantum mechanics you you
mentioned on which i've been involved is
probably the the young kid on the block
is much
younger than the others
and it's very close to copenhagen into
the standard textbook in fact i would
say is the closest uh
tentative solution of the problem
to the to the textbook one the textbook
what you write in textbook is that you
study a quantum system but you're
outside it you're in a classical world
no quantum mechanical world
so you described how the system affects
you the classical world how it affects
your apparatus what you measure what you
see
um and it works very well
and the really the mystery is yeah but
what about the classical world i mean
isn't quantum mechanic as well
aren't we made of atoms
and aren't we quantum as well so how can
we have a theory that explain how
quantum stuff affect
us classical stuff if we ourselves
now relational idea is very simple
and it's the following the theory is not
telling us how a quantum system affect
the classical world the theory is
telling us how a system affects any
other system any two physical system
that don't need to be human don't seem
to be memory to be classical anything
if you want to know how one effect
affects the other you use quantum
mechanics
and this is
intense because um
instead of thinking of system with
properties you only are asked to think
of of systems with relations with others
so in a sense
systems by themselves don't exist they
only exist in the way they
they affect the other
that's india and uh
it has a technical side it's uh i'm
defending it and the main argument in
favor of it
i have is that the alternatives are even
worse is there a sense do you think that
we need another paradigm shift
maybe not another einstein but another
collective
switching to to look at the reality in a
different way we don't need a new idea
we need to clarify
the incredible steps ahead that have
happened a hundred years ago
generativity is a incredible step ahead
in our understanding
and quantum mechanics is an incredible
and we just have to uh digest all that
uh like europe had to digest the
copenhagen evolution newton was
certainly capable of repackaging
everything that was fined in the
renaissance in a coherent way and
opening
uh the way to development
um but there have been father
repackaging field theory has been a
complicated repackage and maxwell have
just changed the way of thinking about
what reality is made of i think quantum
mechanics requires us to
change the way we think reality is made
of and so is generativity because space
and time are pretty basic in our
pre-generativistic so i think we're in
the middle of that it's not that we need
something
new nobody put it in my hand it's not
like
somebody says you know what i'm bored i
want to put this thing in so let me just
change my theory so that's gravity
so what kind of
significance or consequences does string
theory lead
why should we care about strong string
theory today well it is the reason we
care about string theory is that we
believe einstein had the correct
description of gravity which is a
geometric picture of how gravity works
by the curvature of space and time
on the other hand we also know at the
microscopic level the tiniest level of
quantum mechanics is important how the
atoms work
since we know quantum mechanics is a
fact of life
in the real in the in the real world in
the microscopic regime and einstein's
theory seems to be correct in a
macroscopic description of
gravitational forces
well if you take einstein's theory and
take it to the extreme of smaller and
smaller shorter and shorter microscopic
descriptions of it you better have a
consistent theory with quantum mechanics
and there is no other framework today
which is consistent
with einstein's theory and quantum
mechanics at the same time string theory
is the only candidate we have
which combines einstein's theory with
quantum mechanics in a consistent
framework and how is it that it brings
about that gap between einstein's theory
and quantity it is actually one of the
miracles we don't understand how it does
it what we found is that if you study
these vibrating strings which are these
excitations that we have one of the
modes one of the little modes that these
string have which is very tiny strings
turns out to have exactly the same
properties as a as mediating
gravitational force that is that
exchange of this little thing
between
other particles mediates gravitational
force between them
why it had to have this property is not
clear
but it turned out that this this theory
just does it and so many things in
strictly we don't understand why it
works and it's really magical and part
of the reason we believe in it is that
nobody put it in by hand it's not like
somebody says you know what i'm bored i
want to put this thing in so let me just
change my theory so it has gravity in it
no
pure studies start studying strength
here and they say oh
there's gravity in this i didn't put it
in it where did that come from so it
gives more credibility to the theory
it's kind of brings out things we want
to have without actually putting it in
so we believe that's one of the
beautiful aspects of strengthening this
magical property that things that you
get out of it are more than what you put
in
and what would opponents to string
theory what are their biggest problems
with the theory so the opponents would
rightly point out that there has been
zero experimental verification of string
theory
string theory is a part of science and
all science should be vetted by
experiment no doubt
so why haven't we had experimental
verification of string theory well part
of the issue is
the size of the strings
by theory is 10 to the minus 30
centimeters or smaller
and just to give you a scale that's 10
to the 22 orders of magnitude
smaller than the size of the atom so you
put 10 to the 22 strings next to each
other
10 to the 22 that's
billions of billions of billions next to
each other roughly something of that
word there's a huge number just to get
one atom out of it so it's very
difficult to zoom in to that smaller
space to see that string so therefore
naturally you're going to have
difficulty measuring experimentally
verifiable aspects of it of course we're
trying to
nevertheless try to deduce some
experimental aspects of string theory
which could be
observed observe them be an irrefutable
sign of string theory it's going to be
very difficult and we have some ideas
and in particular in the context of
cosmology we're coming up with a few
ideas for example
that's one of the areas that i have for
example and a few of my colleagues have
been very interested in recently trying
to understand the nature of the dark
energy
what is the dark energy made of we also
have dark matter so
most of the universe in terms of energy
ninety-five percent of it is the form of
dark energy and dark matter combined and
are you our our visible universe our
matter is just five percent of the old
of the universe energy
so what is this 95 made of well street
theory seems to have offers new ideas
about what this is and how they interact
what is the relation between dark energy
and dark matter
so
so one of the one of the
prevailing views up to now has been that
the dark energy the energy that
permeates all the universe is constant
and doesn't change with time
recent ideas that i have worked on with
my colleagues as of a year ago suggest
that the energy of the universe may
actually be changing over time and if
the energy of the universe is going down
for example you see that the
acceleration of the universe will change
and and the idea is that the extension
of the universe in the recent past has
been changing and therefore by detecting
how this how the like you get from
supernova and other other other
astrophysical objects you can detect the
rate of expansion and whether it's
slowing down or not and based on that
you can find with the dark energies
depleting or not so those would be new
signs of connecting strength theory to
observe universes so there could be
different ways we could potentially be
successful in getting experimental
consequences out of string theory
the actual problem comes down to saying
there are certain types of initial
conditions which we do not like
so to answer the question is the time to
give up on our theory of anti-matter i
think the answer is
no
and to see why
i have to briefly explain how all our
current theories work in the foundations
of physics um you have uh you have
something that's called the initial
condition that's a summary of all the
information about the system that you're
trying to describe so in this case it
would be all the particles in the
universe and the universe itself
and then we have something that's called
an evolution equation which acts on that
initial state and tells you what happens
at all other moments in time and
the theories that we currently use they
all work the same way
um so you need this initial condition to
make any prediction with a theory but
the theory cannot itself predict the
initial condition
uh when we say that the universe should
have been
uh you know self-destroyed within a
blink of an eye um
what this means is that we have made an
assumption about a particular initial
condition in that case it's that there
are exactly equal amounts of matter and
antimatter and those should have
destroyed but it's very easy to solve
the problem by just choosing an initial
condition that agrees with what we
observe presently and that's actually
what people also do when they work with
these theories
so the actual problem comes down to
saying there are certain types of
initial conditions which we do not like
and i don't think that this is a serious
problem
what some people think is wrong is that
they do not like
that this initial condition must have
been so that there was a tiny little
amount more of
matter than anti-matter because
otherwise as we already um discussed
they would just have
left behind a lot of photons which is
not what we observe
so the the question is really
in this
i i dare to say beautiful assumption of
symmetry and chart conservation or what
have you uh which we don't know is
correct the assumption is the ratio was
exactly
1.00000 okay and
that does not agree with observation
um instead the ratio was more like
something like 1.00001
okay and i'm saying where one of these
numbers is exactly as simple as the
other number okay so the people who
think that there's something simpler
about the last digit being a zero uh
then it being a one uh don't understand
this requirement of simplicity and uh
without that it comes down to an
argument from beauty and i don't think
that's a scientific criterion which is
why i don't think it's a serious problem
the the kind of theory that we currently
use like the standard model and also
general relativity
they generally have a problem with
certain types of questions when it comes
to an initial value like the the ratio
of matter to anti-matter
but also other things like for example
in cosmology people are discussing the
question why is the curvature of our
universe what it is and that also
goes back to a question of of an initial
condition and there are lots of other um
issues like that
um which you just cannot solve within
the framework of the theories that we
currently use you you need an entirely
different type of theory
that's a good thing for the universe to
have a little bit more matter than
anti-matter
i'd like to go a little bit further
and contemplate what a theory that
explains
the amount of matter versus antimatter
that we see in the initial
conditions because
where
we're in as sadina emphasized a
situation
where our theory is incomplete
in that
knowing the laws of motion is only part
of the physics and the other part that
you need to explain
why our universe is the way it is is as
to be
said the initial conditions
so how would we make a theory of the
initial condition
and related to that how would we make
a theory of all the parameters
in the standard model that come in
to
phenomenon like the asymmetry between
matter and anti-matter
and i'll
quote the american philosopher charles
sanders first
in saying that the only way we can
explain
initial conditions or the laws
themselves
is if they're the result of some
mechanism of
evolution
if they change and there's some
dynamical
explanation for why
that's a good thing for the universe to
have a little bit more matter than
anti-matter
there are two theorems that are
essential
to particle physics that are at stake
here
and when you say something like there's
a flaw
and is should we be responding to the
flaw
this is what you're really referring to
so let's put them on the table
there is a symmetry called cpt
which means take anti-particles reverse
the direction of time and look in the
mirror
and cpt
is a theorem in a certain class of
theories called quantum field theories
that respect both the axioms of
einstein's theory of special relativity
and quantum mechanics if you believe
those
two theories are ultimately correct then
you believe that doing those three
things
must be like doing nothing and that's
relevant because of the role of c to
turn particles into antiparticles
but to turn that
into a prediction that during the the
growth of the universe
there needs there would be
an equal number produced you need
another assumption
as was
demonstrated by sakharov who was one of
the great
soviet theoretical physicists and
cosmologists and that's the assumption
that the universe as it expands is
already is always in thermal equilibrium
so that there's a balanced equation as
in chemistry so the rate of production
of
particles is the same as the rate of
production
of antiparticles
and that's not necessarily true and it's
not difficult for the cosmologists
to
hypothesize
and study scenarios in which during the
expansion
of the universe it was out of
equilibrium and that's all you need you
don't need to overthrow the foundations
i'm i'm the guy who loves to overthrow
the foundation it's completely
conventional
to solve the problem by having the
universe expand so rapidly in the early
stages that it goes out of equilibrium
for a little while
what i'm studying now
is whether
and you're going to tell me i'm crazy
whether it would make sense to say
that the laws of physics
learn
how to be the best laws as the universe
evolves maybe much of this is
before the big bang and that sounds
crazy
but let's note that we have these
intelligent machines
that
we think
can learn and i i'm staying far away
from are they anything like us are they
conscious
i think we will admit that they can
learn
and if i can code
the
instructions
for one of these intelligent or learning
machines
in the laws of the standard model
then
i can envision a situation
where the standard model is what it is
because it learns something
about how to be a universe and i know
that sounding provocatively crazy
but i think it's
the
let me quote find them
if a whole lot of smart people
have failed to solve a problem
despite much much effort
then maybe it's time to turn the problem
on its head
and it might be that you discover it's
an entirely different problem
that does have a solution and i do think
that
it overall the situation in fundamental
physics
is calling for
very for new ideas and different ideas
about what a
theory is and how it relates to
experiment
but i
i think we have if we go there
then everything like this is at stake
you know i i'm going to say the thing
that leah has heard like one one million
times if if you have a law that changes
then you have a different law that tells
you how the law changed so it's again a
law i'm only talking effective field
theory and that's i'm not actually
saying anything profound i'm an
instrumentalist okay if you give me a
theory
and uh i can calculate something with it
and uh it fits to observations i would
call that good theory
and there that other people like to tell
stories about what this mathematics
means okay it may be that the universe
learns or the universe makes new
universes and so on and so forth and i
would just say
well that's a kind of an optimization
problem okay you can you can always uh
look at it from that perspective and and
that's
uh that's fine with me and and i
actually think that um to move on in the
foundations of physics we we kind of
need a theory
like that maybe not exactly this
but
something in this direction and maybe
i i um
so that's kind of a related idea has
been put forward by um david deutsch
um who has this idea of constructor
theory um and i i don't really feel uh
confident enough to to tell you exactly
what this is about but but basically
he's he's saying that
this route that we've been on
um in
particle physics and in cosmology that
we're looking for explanations
going to shorter and shorter distances
and further and further back in time
may have its limits and he's trying to
say that maybe some of those
explanations
may actually be found on larger scales
and uh one of the examples that that
he's given to me is that maybe um the
laws of nature
um are so that they have to be touring
computable okay so he's a computer
person so so that's the kind of problem
he would come up with
and that put some restrictions on how
the laws of nature are
but it's not something that you would
find
by going to shorter and shorter scales
or asking about the initial conditions
of the universe it's a kind of
explanation
that we don't currently think about in
the foundations of physics and i i kind
of feel that we need some entirely new
thought
thoughts of of that order of magnitude
to move on
in particle physics we've been living in
in sort of this
state of growing
dissonance we have made some absolutely
stunning experimental
discoveries in physics in just the last
20 years which is pretty impressive
because two decades isn't an extremely
long time in the world of physics so um
so two
really recent discoveries that come to
mind that i think are relevant for our
discussion are the discovery of
gravitational waves that uh that was
long awaited right and and can confirm
einstein's prediction from general
then of course there was the discovery
of the higgs boson so both of these
discoveries were highly anticipated and
eagerly awaited so and and they
confirmed foundational theoretical work
so it would be difficult to say i think
that the g1s2 result from fermilab is
more significant so i would instead say
that um
that it may be one of the most
transformational results of the 21st
century and transformational because
unlike the two discoveries i just
pointed out
um
it's shedding light on physics that's
outside of our current uh theoretical
frameworks right and so that's what's
that's what's so compelling about it and
um so in particle physics we've been
living in in sort of this um state of
growing dissonance right we how can the
standard model of particle physics do
such a splendid job of predicting
something like the higgs in fact
predicting every single particle and and
finding that it that that's within its
framework um and also doing such um
precision uh predictions so for example
it can predict two parts per trillion
accurately predict two parts per
trillion via the um magnetic moment of
the electron right so so how can an
experiment you know a theory that is um
on such firm ground also be completely
agnostic about the things that we know
right that that there's more matter than
antimatter uh how could it have
absolutely no idea uh where dark matter
comes from so we're living in this state
of uh of
of tension and we've been living there
for uh you know decades now and um and
it's just and it's just growing
and and so i think um
this experiment results which will only
improve in precision because we only
release 10
of our existing data and this result
which is of course
partnership with theoretical predictions
and they will also improve their
precision so these these results will go
forward and and improve and precision um
i think what it's done is it's really
poked a hole in the darkness right
that's what it's done it's given us a
guiding light to where we can start to
go to resolve this tension and what's
exciting is once you see one pinhole
often other pinholes come up why is this
why do we why have we already felt that
we need something more than the standard
model which explains all the particles
um that we know about and and if if that
is the case
what might that extra thing be and do we
get any hints of it from this experiment
a lot of our evidence comes from
astrophysical
signals i mean i mean that the fact that
we know uh they're
we're dominated by dark matter the fact
that we have
you know more matter than antimatter in
the universe the fact that we have no
idea why they're three generations of
leptons why is there an electron muon
and a tau that only vary by you know
their their mass i mean no one
you know
the standard model is agnostic on these
things and and so and so we
we know that we're missing some piece
and so i i feel like we're going around
digging holes right like just trying to
poke around for something where the
standard model breaks so yeah no we were
you know we were quite
fine with breaking the standard model
because that like i said it's a way it's
a way to move forward
all the fingers for dark matter point to
a new subatomic particle and extension
something not in the standard model
the electron version of this moment was
is one of the most incredible precise
results in physics and that's its
agreement with theory with standard
model is to better than one part in a
trillion
but in effect at that level and this is
the leverage the muon provides by being
more massive and renee can comment
exactly on the downsides of the muon
because it decays electrons are stable
much easier beast to study in the lab or
in an accelerator um so the mu you know
an effect that would be imperceptible at
the one part in a trillion level for the
electron is present at about a one part
and a billion level roughly for the muon
so you just get a lot more leverage into
these
virtual antiparticle particle pairs and
so you're tapping into potential if new
physics obviously in sense of new
particles
and and just to connect it back to the
larger theme of our debate um you know
we're searching for new particles the
dark matter particle is you know we
don't know what it is axion neutrolino
whatever there's candidates and so the
sense of this discrepancy of course is
in the direction of some new potentially
new particle that could fit the bill for
things that astrophysicists are keenly
interested in on cern has cern has not
found any supersymmetry evidence not
found other versions of the higgs you
know there's been a bit of a dry spell
there since that spectacular result
almost a decade ago so it's very
poignant the situation we're in because
there's some really amazing things that
could happen if this really pans out
we've got some big in astronomy or
astrophysics you know we've got some
huge dirty laundry to deal with we've
got dark matter and dark energy
you know the two major components of the
universe with
all of us in this room and all the
planets and stars and galaxies in the
universe being a few percent of the
universe that's pretty embarrassing um
so you know and we're grasping you know
so on both sides i think we're sort of
grasping for things here and astronomers
have these two big profound mysteries to
solve about the nature of the universe
we live in and physicists you know
are pretty disappointed that the hints
of super you know the super symmetry or
the grand unified theories that paul was
alluding to the simplest ones have been
ruled out or the simplest or the most
elegant ones have been ruled out and we
could have a whole debate on naturalness
in physics and theory because that's a
that's a big subject too but it's been
pretty pretty slim pickings at cern the
last few years why which is why these
these results we're talking about are so
exciting and just as an aside on the
nature of the why we're looking to
particle physics and and particle
experiments not necessarily with
accelerators many are in deep minds to
solve the dark matter problem um over
the decades by process of elimination
essentially everything else has been
ruled out when it's not black holes it's
not you know wadded up socks in
interstellar space it's not rocks it's
not dust particles
it's there's a little window of
primordial black holes but pretty much
that's been closed and so you know all
the fingers for dark matter point to a
new subatomic particle and extension
something not in the standard model so
it's it's a nice convergence and so
everyone's you know keenly anticipating
where that
signal might come from and how it might
come and as i said there's a lot of
there's dozens of experiments with solid
state detectors and mines that are using
rather different approaches than the
accelerator to look for dark matter
particles but it's it's a valid approach
too so could this be it you know we've
been waiting an awful long time dark
matter evidence has been accumulating
since the late 1970s so it's about time
we just know that the dark matter
particle dark matter outweighs normal
matter by factor five or six uh so we
need a particle that's massive and has a
relic abundance or is is abundant as
protons and neutrons overall in the
universe so there's a huge number of
these particles but it's dark it doesn't
interact with electromagnetic radiation
and that ties
one hand and maybe both hands behind
your back when you're in astronomy you
can just look at its gravity on large
scales and things of course got sort of
desperate in the fact that we just
eliminated things and don't know what it
is so people have been playing around
with gravity modified newtonian dynamics
mond is has been you know sort of like
an egg stain on your chin that won't go
away it's extremely inelegant in physics
terms in some way because you could just
tweak the force law of gravity by not
very much
you know a few percent in the exponent
and you can get rid of the need for dark
matter completely right make it go away
just change plutonian gravity which of
course is not tested on scales beyond
the solar system so that's how dire it's
got that we're playing around with you
know very inelegant you know clujs on
gravity or other
models that actually explain the data
rather well
and and we need insight from physics
basically because the handles on physics
so to the question
you know which is exciting what renee
said i mean if this now if the muon
you know experiments can turn into a
whole industry of doing this kind of
these kind of physics experiments i it's
for me it increases the odds that we
really will in the end nail the dark
matter particle by that root
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv
[Music]
you